[Musique]
bonjour les amis petit matin un peu
frisquet sur les remparts de cette
magnifique ville médiévale de Provins
classés au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO ce matin manger ses beauté et
en Seine-et-Marne comme vous l'avez
compris on va rencontrer le sénateur
Pierre Kuiper oscillateur de ce
département extrêmement rural comme on
le voit et pourtant juste aux portes de
la capitale allez on va retrouver le
sénateur
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur sénateur je suis ravi
de vous rencontrer on est vraiment sur
votre terroir c'est vraiment la ruralité
la plus proche de Paris c'est comme la
Beauce qui génère un état d'esprit s'est
Réali etc la brise c'est aussi ça mais à
l'est de Paris mais en plus avec des
cultures industrielles avec de la
betterave à sucre on produit un peu de
tout et moi-même j'ai été éleveur de
viande bovine voilà aujourd'hui je suis
céréalier je produis de également de
l'orge de brasserie je produis du colza
énergétique pour les carburants un peu
tout quoi toutes ces billes dans le même
panier c'est le bon agriculteur on fait
un tour dans votre village parler un
petit peu il y a 13 ans dans le village
il y a 27 km de voirie deux églises à
l'inventaire deux écoles de châteaux
d'eau et 67 km de réseau d'eau alors
tous les sénateurs ne connaissent pas
aussi bien leur village mais il faut
dire que vous avez été plus longtemps
ici que sénateur au Sénat
ah oui et vous êtes aujourd'hui premier
secrétaire qu'est-ce que c'est le rôle
d'un premier secrétaire et bien d'abord
c'est de surveiller les séances aussi
d'être présent nous moi j'ai mon tableau
de permanence jusque au mois de
septembre 2023 donc vous avez vraiment
du boulot vous
jusqu'à 6h du matin les rendements
agricole les rendements
moderne qu'une institution d'équilibre
par rapport à notre pays on a besoin de
ce bicamerisme et puis lui au Sénat on
ne vote pas par rapport à un dogme on
vote pas non plus par rapport à un parti
on est à la recherche permanente
déséquilibres et du bien fondé pour nos
concitoyens alors je vois qu'on arrive
devant une belle maison en meulière là
c'est quoi c'est la mérite d'osuère le
repos il y a comme vous pouvez le voir
une église et il me fait un fort
fortifiée en hirondelle à la base de
justice là vous avez une particularité
c'est des marnaise vous avez
il a été planté dans toutes les communes
de Seine-et-Marne et c'est un arbre de
vie puisque c'est le seul qui est
résisté à la bombe d'Hiroshima est-ce
que je vais vous dire c'est un arbre qui
vient d'extrêmement Orient du Japon et
de Chine c'est un patrimoine et ce
patrimoine
il faut le garder il faut pas tout raser
je le sénateur
vous êtes venus à la politique par le
monde agricole par le syndicalisme
comment est-ce que comment est-ce que ça
s'est fait très simplement j'étais
président du syndicat agricole FDSEA
devant le département je suis devenu
aussi ensuite président de la Chambre
d'Agriculture et j'ai toujours
accompagné politiquement mes valeurs
républicaines au travers d'une liste sur
lequel j'étais sans pour autant être élu
et puis il s'est trouvé qu'un de mes
sénateurs que Michel well est décédé en
2016 et donc j'étais le suivant de la
liste et j'ai accepté de finir le mandat
de Michel well quand il est décédé
qu'est-ce que vous avez découvert comme
sénateur que vous n'aviez pas
expérimenté comme responsable syndical
dans le dans l'agriculture et comme mère
de village d'abord nous sommes peu
nombreux étant agriculteurs mais il y a
une forte valeur pour défendre la
ruralité l'alimentation et l'agriculture
on voit bien aujourd'hui
au-delà de l'alimentation qui le troll
majeur en tant qu'agriculteur peut aussi
pouvoir produire de nouvelles richesses
ce sénateur j'arrive en Brie première
chose j'ai envie de goûter du brie je
vous suis vous m'emmener on y va c'est
parti
[Musique]
allez c'est parti pour notre périple
Seine-et-Marne et on commence tout de
suite avec une icône du département un
fromage connu dans le monde entier le
brie mais le bruit de Coulommiers que
nous présente Camille et Nicolas ensuite
direction la légumerie ou un autre
Nicolas nous montrera ses beaux légumes
qu'il va chercher partout dans le
département avant de se diriger vers
l'école vers le restaurant scolaire
comme on en a l'habitude mais
aujourd'hui c'est du côté de Lieusaint
ou la cuisine est au petit oignon une
bonne bière par la suite du côté du silo
de courpalais avec la famille Rabourdin
et puis nous irons goûter la moutarde de
province cette moutarde dont la graine
brune et blonde craque délicatement sous
la dent j'emporterai un pot au chef
Aloïs doukand à la Fabrique à
Brie-Comte-Robert et on mettra le
sénateur au travail allez hop sénateur
en cuisine
alors où est-ce qu'on va là monsieur le
sénateur et bien nous allons rencontrer
Nicolas et Camille qui sont éleveurs et
producteurs de Brie de Coulommiers bio
et fermier et fermier bien évidemment
bonjour bonjour Camille
vous allez bien bonjour
le temps est moyen aujourd'hui
c'est un peu un mauvais temps
c'est le temps qui dure dans notre
métier il faut du soleil il faut de la
pluie il faut du froid il faut du chaud
alors on dit toujours que les paysans se
plaignent mais c'est pas vrai ils
attendent le bon temps donc le mauvais
temps c'est le temps qui dure et en
politique c'est pareil ça devrait être
comme ça voilà c'est tout il faut
accepter les choses comme elles sont et
puis quand ça va pas mais il faut
accepter de les modifier alors dites moi
je voyais que vos vaches elles sont en
train de manger du foin là
c'est vous qui le prodigez ce foin alors
nous oui ici sur la ferme on est en
caddie autonomie sur l'alimentation des
animaux on produit le foin on produit
les céréales qu'on va leur donner en
complémentation et surtout on produit
l'herbe des prêts qu'elles vont les
pâturer une majorité de l'année un
animal c'est comme un être humain il
faut savoir le soigner lui donner du bon
médicament la bonne alimentation
et puis aussi la bonne relation humaine
voilà et je voyais tout à l'heure quand
vous passiez toutes les vaches se
tournaient la tête vers vous Camille
papa vers lui vers vous voilà alors vous
vous êtes éleveur bio quel est le retour
que vous avez vous des consommateurs
alors nous on a des consommateurs qui
cherchent exclusivement le bio voilà
pour l'alimentation et il y a toute une
partie de nos consommateurs qui ne
consomment pas exclusivement du bio quoi
qui consomme de manière très variée et
qui vont venir chercher un bon produit
chez nous monsieur le sénateur nous
notre génération c'est vrai qu'on était
attaché à nos Chambres d'agriculture à
la FNSEA qui sont souvent un peu en
guerre avec cette filière bio qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous une conversion
totale de notre France en bio ne serait
pas profitable notamment conservateur
parce que parce qu'on aurait la capacité
de produire bio pour tout le monde je
dirais que l'agriculteur quel qu'il soit
aujourd'hui
son premier intérêt c'est de ne pas
dépenser d'argent et puis il faut savoir
que le consommateur il retrouve son
compte aussi je crois que ils font des
choix il faut des choix de venir acheter
du fromage ici ils font du choix
d'acheter des œufs bio ailleurs
peut-être certains me disent on va
acheter du miel bio je veux bien mais
j'ai encore jamais vu une abeille qui
allait choisir là où elle allait butiner
si c'était bio ou pas bio donc il faut
aussi faire 13 attention
j'ai vis-à-vis du consommateur voilà ce
qui est important c'est que les deux
filières puissent avancer conjointements
dans une dans une direction qui est
meilleur au final quoi la transparence
de de chacun envers le consommateur et
voilà comme voilà comment moi je produis
et c'est le client qui fait son choix
ici c'est un modèle particulier puisque
vous fabriquez un fromage à partir de
votre lait donc le fromage fermier qui a
un nombril de Coulommiers ou Coulommiers
en revanche il y a pas d'AOP non il n'y
a pas de Colomiers actuellement ça c'est
pas à proprement parler du Colomiers
c'est vraiment le brie de Coulommiers ça
désigne un grand fromage maintenant on
fait la même recette qu'un Coulommiers
si on change la taille du moule nous
n'aurons pas le même fromage à la fin et
pas le même goût pour nous c'est le
grand frère du Coulommiers qu'on connaît
alors combien est-ce que vous vendriez
aujourd'hui un brie comme celui-là c'est
autour d'une trentaine d'euros pour 12
litres de lait si vous vendiez le litre
de lait à quelqu'un qui fait un
ramassage pour une laiterie vous le
vendriez combien le litre je pense
retour de 48 centimes autour de 57
donc on valorise cinq fois le lait en le
vendant en fromage en produits finis ça
explique qu'on gagne sa vie en faisant
du fromage et qu'on gagne pas sa vie en
faisant du lait aujourd'hui monsieur le
sénateur quand même d'accord
si vous n'êtes pas comme ça il gagnerait
pas leur vie ce serait pas bien viable
juste pour faire du lait plus personne
ne peut vivre juste du lait sauf avoir
des exploitations extrêmement intensives
et encore
c'est ce que je pense c'est que pour
bien parler du fromage il faut d'abord
le goûter et moi je goûter très bien le
bruit de six mois si vous êtes d'accord
c'est moi qui coupe Camille du coup bien
sûr OK
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour Nicolas bonjour Vincent bonjour
merci je me disais en arrivant chez vous
d'abord je pensais au milieu des champs
une coopérative bio mais même dans les
friches voyez la nature reprend ses
droits il y a des petites peurs des
champs quand même exactement ici vous
êtes dans un bâtiment qui nous permet de
transformer les légumes de nos
agriculteurs c'est pour ça que on n'est
pas au milieu des champs mais on doit
voilà avoir ce type d'outils pour
stocker les légumes et puis ensuite les
transformer dans des bonnes conditions
parce que ça part dans les cantines
scolaires ensuite pour autant il est bio
pour autant tout est bio à 100% une
grosse partie de notre activité ça
consiste aussi à ramasser des produits
dans les fermes de nos producteurs et
d'aller les livrer directement dans les
cantines ou dans les magasins tout n'est
pas transformé et pourquoi aussi on a
décidé de construire ce cet outil de
transformation c'est parce que dans la
région il y avait plus aucune légumerie
plus aucun outil de transformation de
légumes c'est bien de produire local
mais c'est encore mieux si on transforme
localement pour consommer localement
combien est-ce que vous avez de
d'agriculteurs de du département qui
sont des on pourrait dire des importants
comme dans une coopérative viticole
alors aujourd'hui nous on est une
coopérative régionale donc on regroupe
une centaine d'agriculteurs dans la
région Île-de-France et en
Seine-et-Marne il y a à peu près 50
agriculteurs donc la moitié qui sont
implantées et quelle est la production
qui qui passe entre vos murs en matière
de légumes alors ici dans cette
légumerie on va pouvoir transformer
l'équivalent de 4000 à 5000 tonnes de
légumes par an on peut nourrir
énormément d'enfants par conséquent
c'est extrêmement sécurisant pour vos
agriculteurs d'avoir cet outil oui alors
c'est très sécurisant et surtout ça
donne une visibilité à nos agriculteurs
pourquoi grâce au marché public les
marchés publics pour approvisionner les
cantines scolaires de la région ça c'est
un formidable outil pour structurer les
filières agricoles ça donne une
visibilité de 3 à 4 ans avec des volumes
et des prix quasiment garantis et ça
forcément c'est très structurant et donc
la restauration collective
un levier formidable pour transformer le
modèle agricole et le structurer est-ce
que je peux visiter l'intérieur votre
[Musique]
plus difficile pour nous dans notre
modèle de se faire connaître et de faire
une promotion à grande échelle
[Musique]
vous permettez que je goûte allez
merci beaucoup monsieur le sénateur de
m'avoir récupéré cela dit vous avez raté
un truc quand même j'étais désolé pour
vous parce que la légumerie c'était bien
et là on va où nous allons à l'école
l'eau vive de Lieusaint je peux dire
pour ma part un des meilleurs
restaurants
collectif du département
[Musique]
on est attendu bonjour monsieur
bonjour
je vous en prie on va en cuisine direct
[Musique]
donc je vous présente Christine Monroe
la chef de cuisine d'accord et qu'est-ce
qu'il y a au menu alors nous avons du
blé bio aïe oignon échalotte comme à la
maison c'est quoi la base c'est le self
on peut y aller les slips je vous en
prie vous venez avec nous Christine
bonjour mesdames bonjour messieurs
bonjour c'est le déjeuner de l'équipe là
ça va le menu
ici vous vous avez fait le choix avec
quelques communes un petit pôles de
communes qui ont des cuisines c'est ça
tout à fait on a en moyenne 1300 1350
couverts par jour ah ouais tout le monde
réunit en fait on leur laisse le choix
de la quantité que les enfants
souhaitent manger en fonction de
l'appétence des enfants on a fait un
système d'ourson parce que d'un CP1 CM2
oursons aujourd'hui
un truc non seulement j'aurais pris
trois oursons à chaque fois mais
j'aurais mangé les jours sont en plus
dans l'anti gaspillage vous voyez on a
on a acheté des centrifugeuses des
extracteurs de jus sur toutes les
cuisines il nous reste des pommes bah
voilà ce midi on va faire des jus de
pomme pour les enfants qui souhaitent
pouvoir en consommer on leur laisse
également le choix tous les jours d'un
repas végétarien ou non est-ce que ce
pôle qui résiste à l'envahisseur de la
restauration collective de grands
groupes ça à avoir avec une forte
poussée écologiste dans les mairies
complètement nous dans le marché public
que l'on a fait avec Grand Paris Sud sur
les fournisseurs on est à moins de 300
km d'ici est-ce que le fait d'avoir une
municipalité écologiste fait que vous
poussez plus sur le bio par exemple vous
essayez d'être au dessus des quotas oui
les élus nous ont demandé en
de pouvoir proposer 40% de produits bio
alors que de mémoire il fallait qu'on
soit 20% en 2020 c'est le double vous
vous avez un menu qui commence très bas
pour les gens qui sont à faible revenu
on est à 27 centimes
il vous coûte combien alors un repas
maternel on est un euro 90 un repas
élémentaire on est à 2,10 le prix
d'achat le prix d'achat
c'est à part ça ça coûte aux alentours
de 10 €, je suis sur un repas
c'est pas une charge quoi on fait goûter
le blé au céréales
on est là pour ça
[Musique]
un vrai produit du terroir en fait c'est
cuit comme un risotto quoi
c'est un Blaise auto en tout cas bravo
si j'habitais ici à Lieusaint ça me
gênerait pas trop de pays des impôts
locaux en sachant que les plus
défavorisés pour moins de 30 centimes
peuvent avoir un repas comme ça vraiment
c'est une belle initiative ah je vois
que les digestifs ont été servis on
trinque avec le jus de pomme maison
à votre santé
[Musique]
vous savez pierre mine de rien j'ai bien
déjeuné dans cette cantine de Lieusaint
mais là j'ai envie d'une bonne bière on
m'a dit qu'il y avait ça en
Seine-et-Marne bien exception que vous
allez découvrir à courpalec qui
s'appelle La Bière de Brie qui est donc
produite par la famille Rabourdin
[Musique]
dites-moi pierre vous m'emmenez dans un
silo à grain là dans une brasserie
c'était un silo agricole c'est devenu
une brasserie on reste quand même dans
le grain dans les céréales c'est normal
totalement
bonjour Hubert bonjour Pierre bonjour
Vincent ferggio ça sent là-bas
évidemment que ça sent bon on n'y pense
pas forcément mais une bière c'est un
vin de céréales tout à fait on part on
part de la céréale donc l'orge de
brasserie et à la base on est
agriculteur céréalier donc producteur
d'orge de brasserie et il y a une
vingtaine d'années mes parents ont pris
ce pari un peu fou de vouloir
transformer leur orge en bière ça
représente combien d'hectares sur votre
sur votre exploitation alors on va
utiliser à peu près une vingtaine
d'hectares d'orge qui vont être
transformés à la brasserie pour au final
produire à peu près 3 millions de
petites bouteilles on est passé de un
salarié à 12 maintenant donc on essaie
de se développer dans le je suis local
et en essayant de faire revivre un peu
le village de courpalais
je vous montre ça
[Musique]
tout démarre ici pour pour pouvoir
produire la bière ah d'accord tout est
en cuve ah oui on est sur des
fermentations qui sont contrôlés dans
des cuves fermés et seulement à la fin
on va arriver à la partie embouteillage
ces technologique le brassage alors
c'est pas trop compliqué de faire une
bière il y a trois ingrédients c'est de
l'eau du malt d'orge et du houblon le
plus dur c'est de faire deux fois la
même bière et pour faire deux fois la
même bière et bah il faut avoir un petit
peu de matériel exactement avoir une
bonne eau aussi c'est très important
alors ici on maîtrise notre eau pour
avoir l'eau la plus pure possible et
d'une qualité
identique toute l'année donc avec cette
particularité c'est que j'utilise bien
mon orge pour faire ma bière peut-être
qu'un jour on pourra marquer bière
fermière sur nos exploitation en quelque
sorte le houblon ou j'ai pas encore
passé le cap de monter une Houblonnière
j'ai appris que dans la vie il fallait
jamais dire jamais donc peut-être un
jour aujourd'hui c'est un le marché qui
est en pleine explosion vous en
bénéficiez le monde de la bière a
complètement évolué toutes les régions
de France ont aujourd'hui des brasseries
chaque sénateur a une brasserie
aujourd'hui c'est sûr
il y en a même plus plusieurs en 2001 il
y avait allez une quarantaine de
brasseries en France aujourd'hui on est
2500 et on pense qu'on va arriver vers
3000 bientôt bon on parle trop et ça me
donne soif vous voyez ce que je veux
dire et ben on peut aller on peut aller
déguster
allez chacun la sienne toutes les
couleurs dans la bière c'est sûr
toujours avec les voitures qui mettra je
lève mon verre à votre santé et je vous
dis longue vie et que Dieu vous protège
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
allez direction la moutarde de Provins
[Musique]
bonjour monsieur boudinia bonjour Alors
j'ai pas résisté monsieur le sénateur
m'a arrêté dans un champ de moutarde à
côté je vous ai apporté quelques fleurs
la moutarde blanche et ça c'est la
moutarde brune c'est essentiellement
celle-ci qu'on utilise il nous faut à
peu près 400 mille graines pour faire un
kilo un kilo de graines ou un kilo de
moutarde 1 kg de graines 1 kg de graines
alors
à peu près 3 kg de moutarde
j'aimerais savoir pourquoi l'été dernier
il y a eu une telle pénurie de moutarde
dans les rayons des français ce qui
était intéressant c'est qu'on a
découvert que on fabriquait pratiquement
plus de graines en France et que les
moutardiers utilisaient beaucoup de
graines qui venaient du Canada pour
faire de la moutarde en France les
moutardier ont besoin de 30 000 hectares
donc aujourd'hui ils ont quand même
quelques agriculteurs qui en font mais
ça ne suffit pas de toute manière ça ne
suffit pas les règles de l'usage des
produits phytosanitaires ne sont pas les
mêmes au Canada qu'en France ah
peut-être peut-être
gros soucis dans cette production c'est
des insectes au printemps les médisettes
notamment aujourd'hui il y a quand même
un retour un petit peu à fabriquer des
produits il y a un mouvement qui se fait
où on a envie de refaire du local et la
moutarde va en faire partie alors
montrez-moi un peu votre gamme vos
best-sellers j'ai envie de dire quels
sont vos moutarde phares les moutarde de
Farges je dirais que c'est la moutarde
de Provin qui est faite avec du vinaigre
de miel vous voulez goûter moutarde de
crème une moutarde d'Ukraine c'est quoi
l'histoire alors l'histoire c'est une
boulangerie qui est tout près d'ici elle
va régulièrement aider des gens là-bas
elle emmène des produits alimentaires et
tout ça elle a récupéré des graines donc
j'y écoute on va faire une moutarde avec
tes graines et puis ce sera vendu au
profit du crâne voilà
enfin quand même
ça envoie pierre vous savez que
maintenant on va aller cuisiner vous et
moi on va cuisiner des produits du
terroir évidemment
sauce au brie mais je pense qu'on va
utiliser de la moutarde est-ce qu'on
peut vous demander un ou deux pots pour
le chef la moutarde de Provin voilà un
produit d'excellence
pierre Brie-Comte-Robert et on va au
restaurant La Fabrique dont le chef à
Loïs doukan a on le voit là le beau chef
qui est là nous attend pour une cuisine
bistronomique mais c'est vous qui allez
mettre la main à la pâte je vous
préviens
alors j'ai apporté de la moutarde de
Provins normal on est locale d'autant
que c'est le sénateur qui cuisine c'est
lui le chef aujourd'hui d'ailleurs on va
y aller tout de suite parce qu'on a du
boulot c'est une première oui oui mais
une première qui va rester dans les
annales
Aloïs là vous avez un beau poulet il
vient d'où celui-là
aujourd'hui on va utiliser que le
suprême on laisse la peau on laisse la
peau on va faire revenir la le filet et
on va le faire croustiller donc un peu
de fleur de sel
on verse un beau volume d'eau bouillante
frémissante jusqu'à ce que ça tireise
donc ça fait à peu près une vingtaine de
minutes une trentaine de minutes pas
plus
pendant que le poulet cuit chef
qu'est-ce qu'on fait on va demander au
sénateur de nous préparer une sauce à la
moutarde la moutarde on a rapporté de
chez Patrice et voilà
maintenant vous délayer un petit peu la
moutarde dans le vin blanc là c'est
homogène on voit le spécialiste et à
cette moutarde vous allez y rajouter
deux cuillères à soupe de crème fraîche
fermière voilà il faut le généreux
[Musique]
je pense qu'on est parfait
venez pierre on va laisser votre sauce
et le chef travailler il faut que je
vous pose quelques questions quand même
on a compris que la Seine-et-Marne elle
est riche de produits et qu'on ne sait
pas pareil on trouve de tout partout et
puis on trouve surtout une intelligence
des producteurs de vouloir se
diversifier alors là il y a une prise de
risque il y a une prise de risque pour
chacun de s'investir dans un nouveau
métier qui est bien souvent ils ne
connaissent pas et qu'ils apprennent au
fur et à mesure on l'a vu avec la
moutarde on apprend soi-même à faire et
puis on trouve autour de soi des
intelligences qui vous accompagnent qui
vous aident et qui vous et qui vous
conduisent au marché et au marché qu'il
faut développer parce que on a vu aussi
dans la bière c'est bien de produire
mais il faut la commercialiser c'est à
tous c'est une chaîne complète pour
lequel en temps moi en tant que sénateur
je souhaite aider l'ensemble de tous
ceux qui sont les acteurs du bien-être
et du bien vivre à Seine-et-Marne puisse
aboutir donc cette ceinture verte qui a
eu tendance un peu à disparaître autour
de la capitale vous voulez que la
Seine-et-Marne demeure un poumon vert de
l'Île-de-France c'est pour ça qu'il faut
maîtriser le foncier il faut faire en
sorte que on aille pas aujourd'hui
grandir grandir grandir et qu'on puisse
aller sur une certaine forme de
décentralisation et que les départements
soient eux-mêmes les gestionnaires de
leur aménagement c'est important
politiquement ah ça commence à sentir
bon c'est prêt chef ça y est c'est prêt
on a les yeux sur le bifteck pierre ça
on lâche pas des yeux que c'est joli
la sauce du sénateur je vais goûter
votre sauce mais je vous préviens je
suis pas tendre monsieur le sénateur
régalez-vous et vous si vous avez envie
d'aller à la campagne que vous êtes
citadin pensé à la Seine-et-Marne eh oui
c'est pas forcément loin mais c'est très
dépaysant très verts comme vous le
disiez
heureux heureuse comme cette émission
manger ses beautés on se retrouve très
bientôt heureux forcément sur le public
Sénat moi je retape dedans merci j'y
retourne parce que j'ai pas bien goûté
celle-là en fait
[Musique]